by it's the most important thing when
cutting peppers secure the pepper okay
make sure it's nice and stable so first
off thinly top and tail stand it up
right clean the board every time and
then hold it upright slice around try
not to go too deep into the seeds okay
otherwise we get that white part of the
pepper off and that's what turns it
bitter
so keep the seeds intact now from there
straighten up your pepper use the board
that the knife do the work on finger in
front to behind this knuckle protects
the nail and slice nice and fine let the
knife do the work use the butt of the
knife and slice those peppers nice and
thinly this is how you're julienne the
red pepper always cut the pepper skin
side down
skin side up really difficult make sure
those strokes are nice
and in pin peppers like this great for
stir fries great for salads from there
clear down next yellow pepper we're fine
dice similar way top and tail again
literally secure the pepper uprights and
clean down follow the pepper coming
around don't go too far into the center
keep it nice and straight that the knife
to the work keep the seeds intact from
there similar to the julienne cutting
matchsticks all the way to the end
don't worry about the speed be more
precise clean the knife turn it round
uniform them use your knife to uniform
and then look up nice and steady on the
handle forget the speed that will come
keep them nice and tight like
matchsticks we've got a nice fine dice
all the way across lift up
onto your board the green peppers this
one's gonna be a baton a bit thicker
great for stir fries again and great for
salads great for sauces clean the board
secure the pepper work around try not to
take off any of that white stuff inside
so look I've got white on my pepper
there hold it flat side down take the
knife let's get it off leave that on
you've got this bitter aftertaste on the
pepper from there square them up keep
the knife nice and clean at this time
we've got a bit thicker flatten the
pepper down and now we cut the most
amazing battle so we've gone from a fine
julienne to a beautiful battle
straighten the pepper out take off a
little ends nice thick slices and there
we have a beautiful baton free peppers
threeways red pepper julienned yellow
pepper beautifully diced and this is how
you batten the green pepper forget the
rush to speed all about precision